parc des princes coup 9 milliards
anciens contenant 50 mille spectateurs
c'est avec le stade olympique de munich
l'arène sportive la plus moderne
d'europe
les footballeurs qui porte actuellement
le maillot du paris saint germain
football club en sont ils les nouveaux
locataires
après la disparition du racing club de
paris du stade français il ya maintenant
sept ans après aussi diverses alliances
infructueuses avec sedan et joinville le
football parisien avait atteint le creux
de la vague
paris était bien la seule capitale
européenne à ne pas posséder une équipe
de football parmi l'élite
pour ma part que les parisiens sont
restés très traumatisée sensibiliser sur
les deux échecs cuisants que l'on a
connue avec le racing club de paris et
le stade français et que d'autre part de
spectateurs parisiens qui a
d'innombrables distraction à sa
disposition
à partir du moment où ils ne croient
plus tout à fait à quelque chose une
distraction sportives ou une autre a du
mal à adhérer de nouveau c'est à nous
qu'il appartient de les convaincre
larmes de cette conviction la création
en 1970 du paris football club qui
s'allia au stade saint germanois de
cette union naquit le paris saint
germain football club qui opère depuis
cette saison en première division saint
germain en laye département des yvelines
45000 habitants à une vingtaine de
kilomètres à l'ouest de paris c'est dans
cette banlieue qui sent bon la province
que vivent et s'entraînent les 17
joueurs professionnels du paris saint
germain
c'est grâce aux 80 millions que verse
annuellement la ville de paris que
l'équipe professionnelle est à même de
remplir sa mission
mais les choses se sont gâtées ces
dernières semaines car le conseil de
paris entend bien reconduire sa
subvention mais à la seule condition que
paris saint-germain deviennent paris
tout court
d'où cette assemblée générale
extraordinaire qui mise sur tout en
lumière la division entre paris et saint
germain quand on parle de l'europe et je
pense à l'europe sportive car il se
créera comme le reste s'est créé on ne
parle pas de milan san siro et on parle
de milan et pourquoi nous pensons que le
titre de paris football club est tout de
même l'étiquette beaucoup plus
importante que paris saint germain et
d'autre part je dois vous rappeler que
la ville de paris a pris ses
dispositions pour éviter que des clubs
de banlieue se mariant avec des clubs de
paris puisse obtenir les aussi des
subventions de la ville de paris la
ville de paris refuse à saint germain de
voir son nom figurer même par ses seules
initiales dans le sigle de l'équipe
fanion
nous supportons ici tout jusqu'à présent
de l'an supporter tous les frais de
l'entraînement de ses équipes nos
installations les
les équipes de les équipes de réserve
les équipes de juniors
si la ville de paris vers ce 80 millions
d'anciens francs pour deux millions huit
cent onze mille habitants ça fait zéro
savez 24 anciens francs par habitant
mois à l'heure actuelle pour la seule
équipe de football je dépense par les
contribuables de saint germain six fois
plus c'est un problème moral je laisse
de côté l'aspect financier nous n'avons
pas démérité saint germain a été
associée et n'a pu il a fallu saint
germain pour que paris est une équipe en
première division
nous refusons quant à nous de nous
laisser balayer si on ne balaye au
revoir
à